experts say that smiling improves your  health stress level and attractiveness  it boosts your immune system lowers  blood pressure and increases the flow of  endorphins it's a natural drug smiling  is good for you but that didn't stop the  virginia department of motor vehicles  which as part of its effort to develop  super secure driver's licenses has  issued a smile band telling customers to  adopt a neutral expression in their  portraits so what constitutes a smile  this this how about this maybe this one  hmm some fancy pants software will be  the judge so next time you head into the  DMV leave the joke book in your car  because that normally jolly atmosphere  will now turn into a dungeon of gloom  where customers wait in long lines deal  with a dysfunctional bureaucratic  nightmare and never smile